Speaker 1: Speaking of Mike Lyndell, by the
way, let's get to our today's voicemail.
If you have a message for me, I'm still catching
up.
When I got back from my vacation, I had six
hundred and fifty unlisted voicemails.
I'm now down to about 475.
I'm working through it hopefully by I don't
know, by mid-September I'll have I'll have
worked through all of it.
If you have a voicemail message for me, you
can call two one nine two David P. Here is
a voicemail from someone who I think makes
a really interesting point about my interview
with Mike Lyndell, which was Mike Lyndell
didn't even understand that I was only pretending
to take the interview seriously, and that
was by design.
Let's take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hi, David, this is Joe.
I'm calling.
Yeah.
Was on.
I just watched your interview with Mike Lendell.
Wow.
I have to commend you on the professionalism
that you showed throughout that interview.
Absolutely amazing.
And on the other hand, I feel so bad for Mike.
He did not understand at all.
What was going on in that interview?
You were absolutely amazing, but I hope that
man gets some help.
Yeah.
It's just sad what's going on with him.
Yes, very, very sad.
It is once again, huge fan love everything
you do.
I try to watch as much as I can.
Thank you.
And keep up the good work.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So, you know, I got I mentioned this a little
bit before.
There were people who were upset with my approach
and the Mike Pillow interview saying, David,
you let him get away with saying crazy stuff.
It's not that I let him get away.
It's that I've done enough of these interviews
where I know that if I just press every single
statement, we don't go anywhere.
And often the guest gets angry with me and
hangs up.
So my approach was, let me pretend to take
this seriously.
If it's as if it's a real interview, as if
this guy is saying anything of actually connected
to the real world substance.
And let's just see where he goes with the
stuff.
And some people got it.
Some people didn't.
Some people like that.
Listen, I that's that was my approach.
And it's an approach I've taken with other
cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs.
I guess maybe next time we'll take a different
approach.
We have a great bonus show planned for you
today.
We've hopefully worked out most of the kinks
from the standpoint of the bonus show.
The House has passed the John Lewis voting
rights bill and it is being sent to the Senate.
It will be a tougher fight in the Senate.
And we'll talk about what the outlook is in
the Senate.
Airbnb is going to be providing housing to
about 20000 Afghan refugees around the world
at no cost.
Very interesting and interesting to see different
for profit companies now getting weighing
in in some way participating.
Is it posturing?
Is it a political statement?
Is it both?
Is it marketing?
And we'll talk about that.
We'll get Pat's opinion.
And Oregon is implementing a mask mandate
outdoors, outdoors, where there is no evidence
the virus actually spreads regardless of vaccination
status.
And my my question is.
I'm all on board with the indoor because we
know what the spread is indoor, do you lose
people when you go beyond that and go back
to the outdoor stuff, which I think we had
figured out, are we better off actually sticking
to the science on that?
We'll discuss that and more on today's bonus
show.
How do you get access to the bonus show?
Very simple.
Two ways.
One, get a membership at join Pakman Dotcom.
Very easy.
You'll be signed up in 30 seconds and you'll
be listening to or watching today's bonus
show.
Second option, if you prefer to pledge on
Patreon, go to Patreus dotcom slash David
Pakman show, make a pledge and you will also
be able to access the bonus show.
I will see you then.
We're here all week and next week will be
off on Monday, Labor Day.
But many, many shows between
Unidentified: now and then.